♪ ♪
>> Tucker: AN ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANT CHARGED WITH HOMICIDE
HAS BEEN RELEASED AND IS OUT ON
THE STREETS TONIGHT BECAUSE
POLITICIANS IN DENVER HAVE
DECIDED THAT KEEPING OUR
COUNTRY'S BORDERS OPEN IS A
HIGHER PRIORITY THAN PROTECTING
OUR CITIZENS.
POLICE SAY THAT HE KILLED A
TRUCK DRIVER IN A HIT-AND-RUN.
FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT WANTED
HIM HELD IN CUSTODY.
BUT THANKS TO THE DENVER
SANCTUARY CITY POLICY
AUTHORITIES REFUSED AND THEY DID
NOT LET HIM GO.
ON FRIDAY NIGHT PAUL REYES SAID
THAT THAT WAS NOT GOING TO
HAPPEN.
IF THE PROGRESSIVES AND DENVER
WERE NOT TRYING TO PROTECT THE
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS AT THE
EXPENSE OF PUBLIC SAFETY.
WATCH LIST.
>> WHY WOULD YOU NOT CALL AND
SAY THAT THIS GUY IS LEAVING AT
THIS HOUR AND BE WAITING FOR
HIM?
WHY WOULD THEY NOT DO THAT?
>> BECAUSE I.C.E. HAS HAD THAT
THEIR ISSUE ON A WEEKLY BASIS
BETWEEN 35 AND 40,000 TO ATTAIN.
>> Tucker: TALKING ABOUT THIS
GUY.
WHY WOULD THEY NOT DO IT IN THIS
SPECIFIC CASE?
SPEAK OF THE REASON THAT THEY
DID NOT WAS BECAUSE, AGAIN,
I.C.E. DID NOT MAKE HIM A
PRIORITY BY FAILING -- BECAUSE
THEY DID NOT GET THE WARRANTS,
THE --
>> Tucker: THEY DO NOT NEED A
WARRANT.
YOU ARE BEING DISINGENUOUS.
THEY ARE NOT DOING IT'S BECAUSE
THEY DON'T CARE, THAT IS THE
TRUTH AND YOU KNOW IT.
>> Tucker: HE WAS BEING
DISINGENUOUS, I.C.E. ASKED FOR
NOTICE AS HE WAS GOING TO BE
RELEASED, BUT THE DEPUTIES IN
DENVER REFUSED AFTER HE POSTED A
$25,000 BOND, HE WAS RELEASED
AT ABOUT 5:30 P.M. ON SATURDAY
EVENING.
I.C.E. WAS NOT NOTIFIED FOR MORE
THAN AN HOUR AND BY THAT TIME HE
WAS GONE.
NOW ON THE LOOSE, AN IMMIGRANT
FUGITIVE.
SO A PERSON IS DEAD AND ALL THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY CAN THINK OF IS
HOW TO PROTECT THE KILLER FROM
DEPORTATION?
THAT IS NORMAL ON THE LEFT.
IN OAKLAND, CALIFORNIA,
AUTHORITIES WANTED TO ARREST
CHILD MOLESTERS AND MEMBERS, BUT
THE MAYOR WARNING THEM BEFORE
THE FEDS COULD SHOW UP.
A WOMAN CALLED PROMO ALLOW US
LUNA WAS CAUGHT ON CAMERA.
PROBABLY SAW IT TODAY.
SHE WAS DEDUCTED FROM HER
FAMILY, TURNS OUT THAT SHE WAS
WANTED ON HUMAN TRAFFICKING
CHARGES, THAT MAY NOT HAVE MADE
YOUR FACEBOOK FEED.
IN BALTIMORE, ONE OF THE POOREST
CITIES IN THE COUNTRY, OFFICIALS
CUT CITY FUNDING FOR